Dave LeBron you've now played Five
Seasons in counting with ad that's more
than you played with Dwayne and Chris
posos in Miami that's more than you
played with Kyrie and Kevin in Cleveland
what has he meant to your
career um I mean everything I mean
especially at the later stag of my
career you know to be able to get you
know a young hungry you know you know
alpha male to go out there and just do
the things that he do um it's definitely
you know giving me um an opportunity to
be able to not only watch as he continue
to grow um but also be able to try to
inspire him as well you know as he
continue to grow in his career and vice
versa so you know I feel like you know
when we're on the floor together we're
healthy um we know what we're capable of
doing we just played too many games
together we've shared too many moments
together um played in too many big
moments together to fail each other so
um you know it's been it's been
everything you know like I said
especially at the later stage of my
career the
Bri